you're saying that there's no sport that
a woman could beat a man in pole dancing
oh you know no you seen those India
[Music]
this article is submitted by
bort Quan
sounds like Fort submitted it a bearded
Pro Power lifter entered a women's
competition in Canada
and smash the record held by a trans
lifter who was watching oh bring it this
is uh death to women's sports I've been
saying it for years what's your favorite
woman sport I don't have one watch if
you had to pick one I don't have one you
have to pick one yeah yeah there's a gun
in your head there's yeah there's a gun
everywhere on you volleyball tennis
tennis I like volley they said Tetris
women's tennis is fire dude yeah you
know um recently I forgot if it was the
swimming Associates one of one of these
big Sports Authorities made an
announcement saying like [__] um if
you are a biological male uh if you had
puberty you can't go into the sport oh
that's actually
um that's the world Athletics Commission
because it would be too entertaining to
watch you
you'd be too spectacular so World
Athletics has banned transgender people
from women's Elite competitions in an
effort to protect the rights of female
competitors athletes will be banned from
competing as a woman if they underwent
puberty as a male with World Athletics
president sebco commenting that while
the move will cause a Ruckus In the
sporting world it was a decision made in
by the overarching principle of fairness
no I disagree I think we should have
equality and it doesn't matter if you
had 30 years of testosterone in you you
should be able to compete if you
identify as a woman that sounds like
sarcasm no it's not I agree completely
but I'm not sarcastic because it
geez if you imagine just a dude in the
WNBA just like [__] backwards Duncan
all over the place dude just throwing
the ball it's called Juwanna Man I just
walk in for half it's called jewelry
it's kind of fun there you go I love
Juwanna it's like watching a guy with
trampoline shoes just [__] go all
over the [__] place so he's got
Springs at his feet that's like me at an
elementary school Court dude
playing against fourth graders Loki
there's nothing more powerful than that
feeling if you're uh a grown adult male
and you're playing with like Raiders
playing in god mode do you think that'll
happen do you think the wnb will
eventually have a trends
trans department no no department just a
player straight up like straight up
Duncan that's the scary part right it's
slowly leaking into like the more like
Fringe Sports and then they'll
eventually make its way mainstream and
then I think that's when like people are
gonna really gonna put their foot down
like four or again I just don't know
what everyone's so afraid of like better
highlights
jeez is there a sport that you think
could benefit from
like a male being in a woman's sport
like a biological male yeah a biological
man being is that all of them yeah they
understand it set us up no no
would be the best though like what would
be the most entertaining literally all
of them probably basketball pick one
women's breastfeeding as a sport I don't
think so I think you're wrong on that is
there do you think there's a sport like
a male sport where if a woman played it
she would actually be objectively better
there is one which one uh ultra marathon
runner the number one person is a lady
and she beat second place by I think
almost 24 hours now try watching it is
that is that actually segregated by
gender no it's all it's whatever Florida
has that always been a unisex company if
you could have balls or vagina or ball
if you could do whatever the [__] you
want and you run it's just the fastest
human being but that's what I'm saying
those are those aren't usually
segregated by gender anyway so he's
probably asking on a specifically male
only men oh like a like it's this sport
was designed for this or this league was
where there's like immense and then
there's a women's and if a woman went to
the man's side she would actually smoke
the dudes is there something like that I
think you're trying to like defeat
calculus
[Laughter]
possible
oh I see
I don't think we're seeing the same
thing no what I'm saying is I know I
believe women what do you think what do
you think oh he's like this is a
rhetorical setup again no no it just
you're saying that there's no sport that
a woman could beat a man in or be more
entertained pole dancing
oh you know no you seen those Indian
pole that's guys yeah the guy's like
one-handing the whole thing damn okay so
back to this this dude this this person
Avi silverberg the head coach for Team
Canada power lifting for more than 10
years entered Saturday's Heroes Classic
Tournament in Alberta after identifying
as a female
this is the [__] with the
full-on beard right yeah yeah he's just
a guy my title he wrote no I think he's
he's doing it to prove a point oh so
he's not actually like he just [__]
bubbled the other thing on the Scantron
yeah and then he and then casually
benched nearly 370 pounds beating the
current Alberta women's record by almost
100 pounds so 100 pounds that record
which was 275 pounds was held by a trans
athlete and uh Ann Andres who was seen
watching silverbird while volunteering
at the event so biological mail a a
trans athlete like a trans beat another
trans right yeah uh but the other I
think no the the other one was a
transaction athlete this one I think
just identified
it sounds like he just did that to prove
a point looks like a woman to me
I'll show you guys the image I guess see
that people want to play games dude this
was gonna happen the [__] top 30 are
all gonna be identified as women and
we're not even gonna have like women who
actually care about the sport like end
up making into the rankings and the
history this is this is the uh the
female quote-unquote female that won the
conflict that's the theme set of tits on
them
her eyes up here buddy
so prior to that there's no like
reputable like cultural identifying as a
woman in everyday life well we're just
in that that uh weird gray area how dare
you out this stuff is happening kind of
like for the first time right you can't
even countries different League I mean
like she might be bad at directions I
don't know that's true
yeah she wrapped her car around the
street
see how they parked that's not bad dude
[__] like this makes me kind of sad dude
[__] yeah man not just because all of it
is Annoying It's all annoying
all of it it's hacking it's annoying
keep speaking on it you know they should
just cancel powerlifting from now on if
this is end it all happened just end it
all you can't have anything blow it up
yeah exactly but let me ask you this
when's the last time people were talking
about power lifting and mass and now all
of a sudden people are hella talking
about it that's true
I don't
know look I've been look it's just one
of those things where when you're
watching someone do something for the
first time it is crazy right so watching
like a woman lift 250 pounds and be like
that's the record is like not that nuts
because like we're watching dudes
[__] lifting brick houses and stuff
so so watching you know now in women's
sports you have like you see the [__]
metal bar bending as a as a chick is
taking like you know a [__]
huge bar of whatever weight it's even
worse even when she looks like that even
when the girl looks like the the people
that are competing the next day
quick quick fix this is the idea of it
like almost like representation
if he was wearing pink I think it would
true true if he was wearing pink and
purple hair yeah that's fine purple hair
then it would fly yeah just quick little
tweaks I actually Workshop really close
on this I actually want Sports to go the
other direction where you can do
everything and anything to enhance
yourself male or female and let them all
go wild technology drugs whatever I want
to see like the craziest [__] I want to
see one day like some sprinters come
with like robotic legs dude what's the
last time anyone gave a [__] about Major
League Baseball is when the juicers were
it was juicer versus juicers Barry Bonds
versus Sammy Sosa for the home run home
run and that was sick everyone at my
school was talking about it well he's
gonna hit 60 home runs I didn't even
know the year before that that 60 home
runs was the record yeah like I hadn't
even heard of it and all you got all
these [__] rooted out dudes injecting
their [__] balls and then now all of
a sudden baseball is interesting again
that's the last time I remember baseball
I say bring it yeah dude for for
baseball that needs to have steroids we
need to get [__] Berry bonds into
wear wearing a dress
soft against little girls the women's
softball put them in a skirt [__] it do
a t-ball dude am I gonna put them up
exactly dude let's see it let's see what
happens it would be more entertaining I
gotta admit that [__] cyborgs super
crazy genetically modified humans that
would be the best there's got to be a
leak to that maybe they should just get
paid more because they will really know
at that that point it's like who who
cares male or female I just want to see
the best that's it not only the best the
biggest cheaters even if people are like
dying like right after cheater like
you're not even meant to be a [__]
athlete but you your whole body 90 of it
is robot and that's why you're the
sickest you have Jack's arms yeah it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen but then
but then people will probably be like
dying like a week later and stuff like
that that'll be fine too
Coliseum Style baby let's go dude you
gotta be fired up are there women's
divisions of like dexterity based sports
that like kind of like darts or bowling
are there like women divisions of that
uh sharp shooting or I think they I
think don't they aren't they better are
women better at Sharp Shooting I think
they are I think they are [__] Arrow
[__] Arrow [__] women women do the Arrow
Shoes I think like they're better at
non-televised sports oh my God
laughs